if you take a quick look at this so you
don't see anything
okay the only thing that might give it
away is this part was recluded again
so that's an indication that somebody
open it up and glue it back again
now you can see the
here the vein if I can call it so one
substance here and the other one might
be on the other side
[Music]
ah
all right we have a white powder
right there here we're gonna stop
because we're gonna make sure that this
is not fentanyl so what we're gonna do
right now
we're gonna test it so we got the
goggles let me change mask just to make
sure and that's what we gotta do to stay
safe
all right
foreign
[Applause]
it's not as toxic as fentanyl so we're
gonna try to extract it see how much it
weighs and as you can see probably it's
going to be left gonna take us a long
time to do it but that's okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and we save the day
[Music]
well the good thing about this is once
you start getting the hang of it becomes
easier and faster right on
at least four
all right I think we've got everything
so we're gonna go and start waiting and
find out how much cocaine we have
out of the 15 Parcels 14 came positive
so we will wait 14 parcels and find out
how much drug do we have
and it's gonna be 89 grams
94 but this is a hundred regardless of
how small or how big the cocaine
Japanese we're always trying to
intercept it
because it's always going to cause harm
to our community
okay last one and we're done there's
gonna be our 14 back
86.
one and a half kill of cocaine
[Music]
today we accomplish our mission
tomorrow is another day and tomorrow
we will do it all over again
you mail it we're going to nail it
[Music]